I think there's a lot of frustrated
women out there who just want meant to
be a bit more confident when men are
screw-ups who don't keep their word who
don't do what they say they were going
to do and eventually they're like [__]
this and at that point women should
really know you're already done with
them I've been there yeah of course
because you're a very competent woman
and you will be able to figure out a
man's incompetency very quickly I'm sure
but for a lot of women they keep hoping
for a change it ain't coming I did start
nitpicking he never did what he said he
was gonna do I don't need a son I want a
partner I want you to be
women find themselves wearing the pants
for men who aren't men as in grown men
still in that teenage boy phase of their
life and that's why women will stay up
in age all the time
the true Geordie podcast